selber Korea die sind Eyeliner gekauft
der heißt Tier Eyeliner also Träne ich
weiß aber bis heute nicht wohin damit
ich mache es eigentlich immer hier in
die müde so rein ich habe gerade geweint
Eyeliner
ich bin jetzt richtig
einfach okay ein zweites Mal ey voll der
geile Trend kaum noch Zeit haben aber
ich mache mich jetzt mal eben kurz
fertig ich wette es weil man Fake und
die Leute hatten noch ewig Zeit und sie
haben sich zwei Stunden lang geschminkt
das ist das Schlimmste wenn das passiert
ne meine Eyeliner sind Geschwister aber
keine Zwillinge richtig die nehmen zu
heftig ich mehr kaum unterschied ich bin
zu alt für sowas geworden Leute ich
werde dieses Jahr 30 wann kann man
eigentlich als Youtuberin Rente gehen
gar nicht stimmt klebe klebe klebe
solange wie ich lebe gut und ich kleine
Brille anziehen hi ja ich bin Vanessa
ich dürfte Gästeliste ich möchte
übrigens dass das auf meinem Grab steht
Vanessa stand immer auf der Gästeliste